well Democrats also found some success
in the races for governor they flipped
at least four governorships two of them
in states that voted for President Trump
in 2016 but Georgia's high-profile
governor's race is still undecided
Republican Brian camp holds a narrow
lead over Democrat Stacey Abrams who's
trying to be the first female
african-american governor in US history
she told supporters overnight she will
not concede we cannot seize it until all
voices are heard and I promise you
tonight we're going to make sure that
every vote is counted Kemp meantime says
he is confident of victory a very strong
lead in folks and folks make no mistake
the math is on our side to win this
election
mark Strassmann is at the Georgia State
Capitol in Atlanta with the latest good
morning mark good morning
there are still potentially tens of
thousands of ballots left to be counted
in this election and Stacey Abrams and
her team believe that could be enough to
swing this election in her favor and
push it toward a runoff last night they
were still counting volunteers counting
absentee and provisional ballots for
hours Abraham's team says that process
will continue this morning and there's
hope but problems arose in several
counties last night in some precincts
the polls closed three hours later than
planned because of long lines and voting
machine problems in one precinct in
Fulton County a judge extended voting
for two hours because the precinct only
got three machines it was supposed to
get eight during the contentious race
each side accused the other of
misconduct Abrams accused Kemp of voter
suppression tactics while Kemp accused
Democrats here of attempting to hack the
voter rolls he gave no evidence Georgia
law requires the winning candidate to
get 50% plus one vote at least otherwise
it heads to a runoff it would be the
first gubernatorial runoff in the
state's history John all right mark
Strassmann thank you Mark